[Music]
oh did you watch the mask singer on
Wednesday a lot of people including
panelists Robin Thicke are speculating
that the star inside that rabbit costume
is in singer Joey Fatone and maybe we'll
find out next Wednesday on Fox I love
that show and in the meantime Joey is
hosting his own new game show that's
common knowledge but how much does Joey
know about his own trivia what was the
only and sync single to top the
Billboard Hot 100
[Music]
how many Grammy nominations didn't Cinco
see gosh I want to say four three or
four there's more shows what I know we
were nominated never won eight eight
holy crap I live in the vida loca what
was the first sitcom that NSYNC made a
guest appearance on this February of
1999 I want to say it was Sabrina okay
clearly Joey wouldn't do so well if
NSYNC was a category on his new game
show two teams of three test their
common knowledge in a bid for the grand
prize you guys what do you think makes
you a great game show host what you see
is what you get I'm not sugarcoating
anything I'm not trying to be like hey
was founded in what country took these
is one of the great late what any
celebrity cameos Oh nope just makes you
love me right now that's it well didn't
need anybody else
no no it's really fun to watch other
people of tell miserably it's a lot of
fun
what a wonderful attitude to have
congratulations to Joey on all of his
success common knowledge premieres
Monday on the game show network
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]